france and england later britain haven't
exactly had the greatest bond throughout
history both have claimed the others
thrown they fought many wars against the
other and their relationship often finds
ways of finding new lows yet the last
war between the two was during the reign
of napoleon and for the 200 years after
this not only have the two kept the
peace but they've even become allies
which raises the question why why did
britain and france stop fighting so
after napoleon had been thoroughly dealt
with britain was sure to invite france
to the congress of vienna in which the
new europe would be built and the reason
for this was simple fear of russia
immediately after the fall of napoleon
and the restoration of the bourbon
britain and france came to an agreement
to consult one another if there were any
european crises particularly crises
concerning russia after the congress
europe was mostly at peace until the
crimean war this saw britain and france
team up to limit russia's power and
expansion and they further worked
together during the opium wars which
meant britain and france had just
discovered something that they both had
in common putting other nations down
which led to the birth of a mutually
beneficial relationship britain would
let france take the lead on european
affairs and in return britain wouldn't
have to deal with european affairs and
would be free to concentrate on its
global empire this didn't mean that the
two were now friends or allies when
napoleon iii warned britain of a rising
prussia the british saw it as nothing
more than a french attempt to conquer
belgium and luxembourg which was
confirmed when napoleon tried to gain
both in return for neutrality in the
austro-prussian war bismarck said maybe
and when it was time for napoleon to buy
luxembourg he changed his mind and
threatened war britain mediated and
decided that luxembourg wouldn't be sold
which damaged relations this wouldn't
improve too much until after napoleon
iii was ousted during the
franco-prussian war which ended in the
unification of germany this concerned
britain and embarrassed france but with
napoleon the third no longer in charge
relations between the two soured again
this was mostly due to overlapping
colonial ambitions in africa france had
ambitions across much of the continent's
north and it wanted to control the lands
from west to east and link their
colonies britain wanted the same but
from north to south and tensions fled
britain made preparations for war and
began to mobilize and the french were
forced to back down this was mostly
because france was internationally
isolated at this time and it wanted to
keep britain friendly in case of war
against germany and so britain and
france remained distant until kaiser
wilhelm ii of germany decided that it
would be a great idea to adopt an
aggressive foreign policy in particular
he pushed for a massive naval buildup to
challenge britain's royal navy which
forced britain to seek closer relations
to france as such it joined the antonte
which wasn't a formal alliance but
essentially a declaration of good
intentions as you'll know world war one
kicked off and britain at first wasn't
too keen on joining it was only when
belgium was invaded and the british
leaders saw that an ascendant germany
could challenge its global empire that
they got involved and after this the
two's interests aligned neither wanted a
resurgent germany after the war both
were suspicious of communism and they
desperately wanted to keep their empires
which is why barring a few exceptions
britain and france were thereafter on
each other's sides since both saw that
allying together would help them to
maintain their influence and so britain
and france became friends for one simple
reason fear fear of losing their status
as global powers from russia germany the
soviet union and to an extent the united
states
i hope you enjoyed this episode and
thank you for watching with a special
thanks to my patrons james bisonette
kelly money maker mr wolf sky chappelle
core show wolf jerry lambda in adam
stalter jordan longley rod d martin wyan
hockey spencer lightfoot captain cydog
marvin cassell gustav swan buggily
wiggly words about books podcast robert
wetzel winston k wood aaron the white
matthew shipley alex schwinn maggie
paxkowski corey turner anthony beckett
copper tone the mukwopa spinning three
plates charles the first ben evinson and
scottish trekkie